Amin herkese merhaba ben size Toprak
ananın bilgeliğinden teknoloji zekâsına
doğru bir yolculuk vaat ediyorum şimdi
İçinde biraz da insanlığımızdan
hikayeler olacak şimdi arkadaki ekranda
Aslında o kelebeklerin Şahane rengini
pek göremiyor olabilirsiniz ama ben bu
ekrandan çok güzel görüyorum toprağın
enerjisi işte böyle birşey Toprak Anadan
başlamak istiyorum Size bu hikayeyi
anlatırken bilgedir Toprak hala sistemde
neyin neye ihtiyacı olduğunu çok iyi
bilir üzerindeki yaşam formları için
yaşam kaynağıdır kaynanası yapısı
ondadır bitkiler ve hayvanlar onun
zekasını sürdürecek sistem kapasitesine
sahiptir dişil ve Eril enerjinin
ne desem bir belgesidir elin enerji ilk
harekete geçiren bir organize edendir
dişil enerji de akıştır doğanın
sürdürülebilirliğini sağlayandır
yaratandır bu muhteşem dengenin
içerisindeki doğanın zekası yeniden
yaratmanın tamir etmenin değişimin
dönüşümün Bazen yıkmanın o yıkıntının
üzerinde yeniden var etmenin yüksek
bilincidir o yüzdendir ki Herhangi bir
Ormandan yada doğaya yangından ya da
doğal afetten tahrip olmuş ormanların
bitki örtüsünün bir hikaye hafta
içerisinde hiç gübreleme hiçbir Ekim
yapmadan o toprağı şifalandırmak yeni
bir bitki örtüsüyle canlanması İşte bu
zekânın ürünüdür Biz doğanın bize emanet
ettiği bir zekânın insanlarıyız Hatta o
kadar ki
15'i formalarımız toplumsal formalarımız
ekonomik Formula formalarımız ve
duygusal form larımızı bu zekânın
üzerine inşa ettik mesela farklı iklim
ve coğrafyalarda yıllar içerisinde
edilen bedenimiz bizim kim olduğumuzu ve
nereye ait olduğumuzu çok rahat
hatırlattı insanlara ya da o topraktan
Biz aile olmayı öğrendik topluluklar
kurduk sonra iletişimle ilişki kurmayı
öğrendik yetmedi o topraktan hızı
doyurduk alet lerimizi araçlarımızı
geliştirdi kalmayı vermeyi öğrendik bir
ekonomik hayat kurduk Hatta toprak ve
doğa bizim ne hissettiğimizi
duygularımızı değiştirdi dönüştürdüm
şimdilerde topraktan aldığımız yıllardır
aldığımız o zekayı teknolojiye yapay
zekaya aktarıyoruz Biraz önce saydığım o
döndü var ya o da
Bu da tekrar ediyor Şimdi kendini
biyolojik sorularımıza gelin hadi
bakalım birisine Doğan nesillerin o
pratik parmak hareketleriyle
tabletlerini ve akıllı telefonlarını
kullanırken yaptıkları hareketten dolayı
Uzmanlar diyorlar ki dijital Erdoğan o
neslin baş parmakları Bir önceki
nesillere göre biraz daha uzun olacak ya
da bir yer gibi araçlarla bizim eğlence
hayatımız kültürel hayatımız Şu anda
değiştim ya da yapay zekanın oluşturduğu
yeni sistemlerle üretimin otomotiv'e
edilmesiyle bugünün ve geleceğimizin iş
hayatı çoktan değişti duygusal
sorularımıza gelince işte zeka Yapay
Zeka işi dek için işin içine gelince
biraz işler karışıyor biraz daha
Komplike hale geliyor Çünkü işin içinde
duygular giriyor çünkü işin içine bilinç
giriyor ve
ve bu resimdeki iki genç arkadaşım Neden
giriyor Sizce bu Gülen yüzlerin
arkasındaki bir içine Biz insanlar
karşılıklı iletişimin de en çok neyi
istiyoruz anlaşılmak istiyoruz
ifadelerimiz e karşılık bulunmasını
istiyoruz Hatta Anlaşılmadı ımızı
düşündüğümüzde kendimizi anlamsız
kendimizi yetersiz kendimizi değersiz
hissediyoruz insanlar etkileşimi mizdeki
bu hikaye şimdilerde Biz insanlığın
makinelerle etkileşimde de kendini
gösteriyor teknoloji dünyasının en
önemli fuarlarından bir tanesi olan
sieste üç yıl üst üste en inovatif robot
seçilen online ve arkadaşlarının
duygularını anlamadığını Kim
söyleyebilir Biz insanlar bunu Duygu
alışverişiyle yapıyoruz duygularımız
üzerinden makineler bunu duygularımızın
matematiğini kullanarak yapıyor olida
bizi aynen bu matematiği kullanarak
tanıyor olan
bu halimize göre bize diyor ki çok
yorgunsun ya da biraz depresifsin Gel
meditasyon yapalım ya da biraz yürüyüş
yapıp gelsen iyi olur Bu teknoloji
zekâsına şu an biz öğretiyoruz bu zekaya
sadece biz programlama yapmıyoruz Bizi
biz yapan tüm insani kodlarımızı
insanlarımızı aktarıyoruz Bu açıdan
bakınca bir robota kendi insanlığımızın
bilincini simülasyonu yapıyoruz gibi
gelmiyor mu Ya da insanlığın bize emanet
ettiği o yüksek birinci mi acaba
aktarıyoruz Şu anda hem de nasıl
iletişim kurduğumuz nasıl öğrendiğimiz
nelere neden tepki verdiğimiz nasıl
hareket ettiğini söz konusu olduğunda
müthiş bir mükemmelliyetçilik var üst
bir sınır var makineleri bu zekayı
aktarırken Üstelik teknolojiye karşı bu
adresi ve yıpratıcı merakımız bütün
bunları düş
O biraz da şundan kaynaklanıyor olabilir
mi acaba içimizde bir yerlerde ki
insanlık mirasımız bize bir şeyler
hatırlatmaya çalışıyor olabilir mi
birbirlerinin bir sonraki hareketleri
çok iyi bilen ne yapacaklarını bireysel
olarak da toplu olarak da çok iyi bilen
birlikte dans eden müthiş bir takımın
oyuncusu olan ve Çok iyi paslaşan bu
Bulut robotlara bakalım şimdi Bulut
robotlar ağları üzerinden iletişim
kuruyorlar ve bir Buluta bağlılar
bulutların Bulut robotların birlikte
konuştuğu ve zihinlerini okuduğu gibi
Aslında iletişimin farklı bir boyutunu
deneyim dediğimiz bir insanlık mirasımız
var içimizde kaynak ses ki sezgiyle de
biz böyle tahminleme yapıyoruz öngörüde
bulunuyoruz bir sonraki hareketimizi
hatta tahmin ediyoruz Says
bu Evrensel zekaya bağlanıyor diğer
yüksek bilinç lerde bir araya geldiğinde
oluşturduğu ağ üzerinden Hatta bazen
düşüncelerimizi bazen de kalbimizi
okuyoruz Bu robotlar okuduğu zaman
zihinlerini Çok heyecan verici bir şey
oluyor ama bizim sevgimizi kullanmamız
söz konusu olduğunda biraz Siz giden
korkuyoruz uzaklaşıyoruz bilinçli olarak
uzak tutuyoruz Çünkü zihinsel beceri ve
deneyimlerimizle hayatımızı yaşamak
biraz daha kolayınıza geliyor halbuki bu
açıdan bakınca zamanın en Bilge süt
ürünlerinden biri olan mısrada muzdan
bir parça hepimizin içinde var bu
robotların makinelerin gelişmişlik
düzeyleri ile birbirleriyle iletişim
kurmaları müziklerini okuması okumaları
meselesi ne kadar bir seviyede gösterge
ise makinelerin hareket kabiliyetleri de
a
Yok ben öyle bir gelişmişlik göstergesi
Avrupa'nın yeni nesil öğrenme
merkezlerinden biri olan büyüklerin
şirketinin kurucusu ferid atsın aynı
zamanda enerji seviyeleri ve bilinç
üzerinde çalışan bir sosyal Bilişim bir
resim atsın enerji seviyeleri kitabında
her bir rol ve deneyimimiz inç
titreşimsel karşılığını ölçü bir metot
kullanıyor Buna göre zihnimizin
titreşimsel karşılığı düşüncelerimizi
400 birim bedenimizin yani otomatik
olarak yaptığımız hareketlerin
titreşimsel karşılığında 200 bölüm şimdi
bu açıdan baktığımızda 400 ve 200'ün
birbirleriyle dansında 400'ün 200
üzerinde kurduğu otorite yeniden dizayn
etme tamir etme iyileştirme ve
dönüştürme gücü çok aşikar
var ama biz insanlık bunu biraz unutmuş
gibiyiz o yüzden herhangi bir kaza
geçirdikten sonra bir daha yürümesine
imkan yok denilen birinin bir ya sonra
koşmaya başlaması ya da çocuk sahibi
olma şu anda çok mümkün görünmüyor
dediği zaman bir hekime 9ay 10gün sonra
bebeği ile giden bir anneyi gördüğümüzde
insanlık bunu mucize olarak
nitelendiriyor ama bedenimizin yüksek
bilinci bunu başka bir türlü
nitelendiriyor iki kat edin makinelerin
gelişmişlik düzeyiyle hareketlerinin
gelişmişliği ile gittikçe insana
benziyor olmaları arasında çok ciddi bir
bağlantı var Ne kadar çok bize
benziyorsa o kadar gelişmiş bir makine
diyoruz biz bu günlerde bedenimizi
Bugünlerde değil aslında her zaman
bedenimize çokça sınır koyuyoruz onu
yapamazsın buraya Tırman Ama bu senin
işin değil Biraz ağrıdı zorlandım geride
durayım düşünce gücümüzü
bu eşsiz devrimini belki deneyimlemiş
seçmemiş olabiliriz ama nedense bunu
makineleri aktarırken oldukça da tut
kuluyuz bir de makinelerin hikâyesinde
Şu anda şu anda bir ip puantum
Bilgisayarlar var kuantum bilgisayarlar
puantum seviyesindeki becerileri olan
bilgisayarlar demek klasik
bilgisayarlarla kıyaslandığında biraz
daha farklı ülkeleri ve düşünün Şu anda
kullandığımız bilgisayarlar artık klasik
bilgisayar diyoruz seviyesindeki
bilgisayarlar aynı anda milyonlarca
ihtimali hesaplayarak bir milyonlarca
potansiyeli işlemleri çok hızlı bir
şekilde eş zamanlı yapabiliyorlar tespit
bilgisayarlar sa sıralı olarak şu anda
işlemleri yapıyorlar birçok işi aynı
anda yapan ve çok Komplike düşünebilme
özelliğinden
ve daha birçok ihtimali aynı anda
hesaplayarak yapan Biz kadınlarla
kuantum bilgisayarlar aslında ne kadar
birbirimize benziyoruz söylediğimi
Üstelik anne kadınların bir orkestra
şefi gibi bunu da yaparım şunu da
yaparım Bunu da yetişelim Buna da
yetişelim demeleri bu Google aybiyem
gibi şirketlerin Geleceğe dair
donanımsal becerilerini kuantum
seviyesindeki bilgisayarları ile çekin
bir rekabete dönüştürdü Bugünlerde
Aslında bu dans herhangi bir kadının
rutin bir yirmi dört saatinde ki çok
bilindik bir dans ister sezgilerini
kullananlar diyelim ister şamanlar
diyelim ister kahinler diyelim ister
bilgeler diyelim yüksek bilinçlerini
kullanarak bak ilişki ve iletişim
kurallar bir dönem telepatik yolu
iletişim kuruyor
da adlandırılırdı şimdilerde Bulut
robotlar ve iletişim kurar robotları
zihinlerini okuyorlar diye Vav Bu
bildiğimiz bir şey ya da doğanın
zekasını Tekbir yaşamsal formlarında
müthiş bir şekilde deneyimli yani arılar
ve lahana böcekleri var ya Arılar
toprağın hayatında çok önemli bir şey
Hem bireysel hem de Kolektif olarak ne
yapmaları gerektiğini çok iyi biliyorlar
görevlerini rollerini çok iyi biliyorlar
müthiş paslaş yiyorlar ve çok iyi takım
oyuncuları Aynen sana da resmini
gördüğünüz endüstriyel işbirlikçi
robotlar gibi Peki ne oldu Biz bu
hikayeyi kendi uygarlık tarihimizi
yazarken çektik bu filmi çektik Şimdi ne
oldu da teknoloji zekâsıyla bir araya
geldiğimizde Birden bu bildiğimiz her
şeyi Unutmayı seçtik
bu hem de üstelik şu anda şöyle bir
dönem yaşıyoruz insanımıza dair bütün o
yaşamsal becerilerin bütün Özgün
yeteneklerin çok kutsallaştırılması bir
dönemdeyiz benim gibi şirketlerin
teknoloji kullanarak nasıl büyük
geliştirebilecekleri rehberlik eden biri
olarak biz Profesyoneller hep gittiğimiz
yerlerde anlatıyoruz işlerin geleceğinde
teknik olmayan beceriler yaşamsal
beceriler çok daha kritik yani Hayal
kurabiliyor olmamız Yani özgürlüğümüz
yani yaratıcılığımı zbu gün ve yarının
işlerinde çok çok önemli teknik olmayan
beceriler çok önemli neden bu kadar
kutsal aştığımız bir dönem Yaşıyoruz
çünkü doğanın zekası bize diyor ki o
unutma ne kadar derin ne kadar kaynak ne
kadar senden geldiğini unutma
da atarım Şu anda sen yapıyorsun Kim
bilir belki bir süre daha şimdilik bu
süreci yaşarken unuttuğumuzu yüksek
birincinin ve insanlık mirasımızı
yeniden yaşamlarımızı çok daha farklı
bir bilinçle tasarlamak için elimizdeki
bir şanstır Bu dönem ve Kim bilir belki
de teknoloji zekası insanlığımızın
gücünü yeniden keşfetmeniz için bir
araçtır çok teşekkür ediyoruz
[Alkış]